Jack the giant slayer certainly has its
moments keyword moments underline that
[ __ ] moments that can be counted on one
hand but how is the overall film it's
surprisingly quite dull I could not
believe how bored i was like
overwhelmingly bored let's start off
with Jack Jack not an interesting fella
nicholas hoult does a good job of what
he has to work with but the character is
very much under written there's really
not a whole lot given to us to root for
the guy or necessarily feel like we're
on the journey with him and why the [ __ ]
is this movie called Jack the giant
slayer Jack gets in total spoiler alert
two whole kills both times were dumb
luck there's a romantic story here
between Jack and the princess that feels
like the writers put it there because
they needed some type of romantic story
but even that is not that interesting
even McGregor's in this phone he brings
charm when he's on screen he's almost
like winking at the camera but his charm
is certainly not enough to save this
movie enough about the actors let's talk
about the film itself this movie is very
uneven it ships back and forth between
being a silly kids movie and then being
way too mature for little kids it takes
forever to get to the Giants they climb
a [ __ ] Beanstalk for what feels like
forever and then it gets the wife of the
Giants in the sky which sounds like it
would be interesting but it's not it's
just a vacant forest that has a random
trap set up for humans then we finally
get to the Giants just what it's not
that interesting it's not a rewarding
payoffs all the Giants are practically
the same just a bunch of tall retards
with no real way to discern the
characters the worst part of this is
before we even get to the Giants there's
all this mythical fantasy talk about
whether the Giants are legend or not
then the humans finally encounter a
giant after all of the years of hearing
about them and guess how they are pretty
[ __ ] cool about it imagine if Jesus
Christ came back to earth descending
from the clouds above would chariots of
fire in the sky and everyone was like oh
what's up Jesus this film is predictable
very unoriginal has under written
characters uneven tonal shifts boy no
wait no no no
I just remember the best part there's a
moment before the finale where you're
sure this movie is going to end two
thoughts go through your mind one is is
that it not really a payoff the other
one is this thank god this [ __ ]
movies over now the finale is actually
the best part of the movie the thrills
that Artie's in the finale is what this
movie should have been in total but when
the finale is finally over it's like
what a shitty wait indefinitely there's
too much to say about why this film did
not work so all I can really tell you is
this Jack the giant slayer got it wrong
alright guys you can go ahead and tell
me your points below and if you like the
video go ahead and like the video and if
you want to see more upcoming reviews go
ahead and subscribe to my channel and if
you want to see an extended review of
Jack the giant slayer that I do with my
buddy Jerry go ahead and check out our
show reasons to see